well of course they're doing a lot to
highlight because the problem within
racism taking a knee
doing what they're doing this weekend is
a fantastic way because it's so media
attentive and it gets to the imagination
of the public to highlight
the um the problem with racism it does
nothing to cure them but it does it to
highlight them so of course i'd like
them once once now to then actually move
on from you know highlighting just
taking your or what they're actually
doing this weekend
um to that end you've actually written
the book haven't you recently the
uncomfortable truth about racism tell us
about it well it's not to the end of of
to that end in terms of sport or or
football it's about it's about life um
it's uh it's i know some people may
think it'll cause controversy because
it's really about in my opinion the the
the
um to come to the solution uh for racial
and inequality it's not just about race
it's also intersectional about gender
it's also about you know homosexuality
and what we have to do from a bottom
down um approach because we are quite
happy to to look at the elite the
footballers and the actors and the
singers and and female prime ministers
of women in the higher islands of
society and elevate them out of that
negative space where society generally
sees women black people gay people and
feel that we're doing something because
we have more representation up above but
that's not going to change what we have
to do is we have to start down below and
change what's happening down from a
black perspective in the inner cities in
terms of what's going on with life crime
what's going on with you know inequality
in in jobs and education and and change
our perception of the average black
person or the average woman or the
average gay person not elevate the
brilliant ones in that group into these
positions of power and to give the
illusion that we're doing something
because we have more representation up
at the top
you of course um john many of us uh
older viewers will will remember the
abhorrent
racial abuse that you had to deal with
when you were playing football do you do
you feel that you've um
that all of us as a society have made uh
real progression since then
well
the proof is not whether or not it comes
on the field the proof is whether we're
having more opportunities in their
cities for our kids
and where they give more opportunities
um to access to social chair and jobs
and housing and uh whether you know the
average woman so we can give the
illusion because of course we don't hear
any more austerities like we used to um
but that doesn't mean if you look at
what's going on generally speaking that
race isn't getting any better so over
the races with football isn't what it
was back then but that doesn't mean that
racism generally for the majority of
people or sexism or homophobia um is any
different and football can do nothing
about that football can only pass laws
to govern its own house that's not going
to change people's perception so what we
have to change people's perceptions
about what they consider to be people
less than them be they black be they gay
be they female or other or other
dynamics
do you think the united kingdom is
racist as a nation
not more so than anywhere else but i
believe that we are i never mind as a
nation martin luther king said um
that in 1963 that the shallow
understanding of racial bias is much
more detrimental than the total and
absolute
understanding by bad people the shadow
understanding by good people
is worse than the total misunderstanding
by bad people that what he means is that
we believe that as long as we don't
throw it on the field and the ones who
do are racist if we don't rape a woman
we don't we're not sexist the majority
of us would never do that because we
have a shadowless understanding of what
racism and sexism is and we believe it's
a binary either or most of us are sexist
racist homophobic to a certain degree
certain unless a degree but we believe
as long as we don't overtly do something
we are not and most of us are
somewhere in between that and until we
accept it within ourselves and
understand why we are because of how we
have been conditioned to think for
hundreds of years in terms of racial
hierarchy gender hierarchy all of us
nothing will change we wait for the ones
who get caught and it will come down
hard on them and think that's a solution
to the problem but we have to look at
ourselves
okay so once we accept that what do we
do about it
we accept it so then what we do is say
why do we think the way we do and then
we understand that it's how we've been
conditioned to think
oh i think we've lost john this is how
we've been conditioned to sit give me
one second
but you're back sorry you were just
making your point do you forgive me yeah
sorry and because this is how we have
been conditioned to think for hundreds
of years and we believe that a simple
solution is to pass laws it's been
illegal to to rape and kill but people
still do it we have to stop up yes we
have to pass laws to control that that's
what we can do but we have to change
perceptions
and where do those perceptions come from
in the last 3 400 years there's been a
group of people who've been superior to
other groups of people because we have
been lying about
by
their character their worth are they
irish be they black were they women
because this is what we have done in the
last 40 years and we have to deconstruct
that and it's not as simple as saying
everything you've learned to be
conditioned is wrong why because we're
all the same and we're trying to do it
in a very quick simplistic way a lot of
it has to do with elites and non-elites
as well because of course a lot of black
people and women will be allowed to
become elites and not be exploited not
be discriminated against why the group
we belong to still will be and we quit
ourselves that because we have a black
predator president and a female prime
minister it doesn't exist conditioning
has made us feel the way we do and we
have to deconstruct what we have been
conditioned to think which is a very
long process and a very complex process
but we're trying to simplify it by just
saying it's illegal to do it
john barnes um his uh new book uh the
uncomfortable truth about racism out now
john thank you always a pleasure
thank you